GERBRAND CEDER: So what I
want to do today is finish up
Monte Carlo simulation and go
into a little more advanced
things in Monte Carlo
simulation and then
also go into free
energy integrations
and other
coarse-graining methods
so when direct
simulation won't work.
If you remember, I
introduced Monte Carlo
simulation as a way
of importance sampling
and contrasted it
against simple sampling.
What I want to show
you today, there's
actually quite a few things in
between that, in some cases,
can be practical.
Remember the idea
of simple sampling
is that you sample
randomly and then
you weigh with a
probability that's
correct relatively,
where the states have
their correct relative
probability to one another.
Importance sampling is sampling
with the correct probability
and then just averaging
the quantity you sample,
but you can actually sample
with things in between.
So here you're sampling with
a probability proportional
to that exponential
of that Hamiltonian.
Here you're sampling
with no Hamiltonian
and therefore, you have to
correct the probability later.
You can sample with any
Hamiltonian H0, which is not
the true Hamiltonian
of your system,
and then correct for it
in the probabilities.
So if you sample with H0,
then the states you sample
have to be corrected with
the relative probability
of that state, the
relative probability
that you would get with the
correct Hamiltonian versus what
you get with the Hamiltonian
which you decided to sample.
OK?
So this is the Hamiltonian
which we decided to pick,
the states that
go in your sample,
and then this is the
probability correction.
Sorry.
And so whenever you
sample with what's
not the proper Hamiltonian
of your system,
people call it
non-Boltzmann sampling.
Why would you want to do
non-Boltzmann sampling?
Well, it can be relevant if
the particular quantity you're
after in your system
is essentially not
determined by the relevant
thermodynamics states.
Remember, I introduced
this by say,
what if you're looking
at, say, average energy
or average volume or
average magnetization,
then what you
really need to know
is what's the
energy of the states
that the system spent
most of its time in?
But what if a system
spends only a small amount
of its time in certain
states, but those
have the relevant property
that you want to sample?
For example, let's say that
this is a phase space, this
[INAUDIBLE].
So with importance
sampling, you'd
be drawn towards these states.
OK?
I don't know, maybe
the ones that live here
are optically
active or something
like that and the other
ones aren't and you
want to somehow get
a lot of information
of the optical activity
of the material,
you may want to build a
Hamiltonian that drives you
towards these states.
OK?
And as long as you then correct
for the proper probability,
you'll get a proper ensemble.
It's one that's just much
more efficiently biased
towards the regional phase
space where you want to get.
So that's
non-Boltzmann sampling.
Another obvious way is you can
use it to sample phase space
more efficiently.
If you had a phase base
with a lot of local minima,
you may want to define
a new Hamiltonian that
looks like this.
And this is especially relevant
if your Monte Carlo has
some form of dynamics in it.
So in the blue Hamiltonian,
the true Hamiltonian,
it may be very hard to
get out of this minimum
into the next one.
Whereas if you raise
the potential well,
OK, in the red
Hamiltonian it's going
to be much easier
to get out of it.
OK?
So essentially your
flattening your phase space
with the new
Hamiltonian, so it's
going to be much easier
to get out of local minima
and then you can correct
for that probability.
There's a lot of algorithms
these days built on this idea,
not just in Monte
Carlo, but there
are molecular dynamic
schemes, there
are all kinds of
schemes that are
built on this idea of lifting
up the potential wells
and then correcting the
relative probability
or the relative
vibrational frequency
or the relative time you
spend in each potential well.
OK.
You can also do
non-Metropolis Monte Carlo.
This gets even a
little more odd.
Remember that we defined an
acceptable Metropolis as one
where the a priori
probabilities were equal.
So basically in
the Markov chain,
the rate at which I pick
the i state from the j one
as a potential next step in
the Markov chain is symmetric.
It's the same as the rate
at which I pick the j
state from the i state.
j to i and i to j is the same.
You don't necessarily
have to do that.
You can actually
make these rates--
so these are the picking
rates, the rates at which I
try one state from the other,
non-symmetric, and even more,
you can make them dependent
on the Hamiltonian.
And why would you
want to do that?
I'll show you an
example in a second.
It's a way of forcing systems
downhill in energy space
much faster.
So as long as you're correct in
your detailed balance argument,
you'll be OK.
So the important thing is
the detailed balance criteria
because the detailed balance
criteria is the one that
ultimately ensures that
you sample phase space
or that you weigh
states and phase space
with the correct probability.
And so as long as
you correct here--
so if you changed
the W0, you can still
get satisfied detail balanced
by essentially changing
what the acceptance rates are.
PI to J and PJ to I. You
can write out what they are.
Essentially the
ratio of PIJ to PJI
is the factor we had
before, but now you
correct by the relative
weight, which we
did the picking of the states.
OK?
So in the end it's a
fairly trivial correction.
I haven't seen too many examples
of this, but one is this one.
It's force-bias
Monte Carlo, which
almost looks like a
hybrid between Monte
Carlo and molecular dynamics.
You know, I've given you several
times this example of a liquid.
How would you sample a liquid?
In Monte Carlo, you just could
pick random displacements
of an atom within a given range.
One way to actually drive
the system to low energy
faster is not take a random
displacement of the atoms,
but take one that's biased
along the force on that atom.
If you move an atom
down with force,
you're obviously going to
lower the energy mathematically
because the force is the
gradient of the energy.
So you could take a
displacement factor
that has a random component and
that has some component that
depends on the force.
Actually if you
only do this, that's
actually how a lot of static
relaxation schemes work.
For example, in density
functional theory
you calculate the
forces on atoms
and then you relax them assuming
a certain spring constant
typically.
But because you still
have a random element,
this is probably somewhat better
described as mixed dynamics
Monte Carlo methods.
And if you would like
to read more about it,
I think this was one
of the first papers
that kind of introduced them.
So what I want to do is a
couple more case studies
and then show you some
of the complications that
can arise when you do difficult
systems with Monte Carlo
and see how we solve
them, and that'll lead us
into free energy integration.
So this is sort of
a classic paper on--
it's from 1985-- using
Monte Carlo to study surface
segregation in copper nickel.
It uses the embedded atom
method as a potential so,
one of the reasons I
picked it because it
integrates a lot of the
things you've seen in class.
So the idea was to take
random copper nickel alloys
and see which element
segregates to the surface
and then see how the segregation
pattern away from the surface
is, because there's
been a lot of discussion
about that in the literature,
especially around that time.
So what they do is they set up,
just like you would probably,
supercells.
So I think they either
had 24 or 24 or 48 layers,
and then with a certain width.
So here's your supercell.
Again, you can define your
Hamiltonian multiple ways.
You could just seed the system
with a particular concentration
and then you have to decide
which kind of Monte Carlo
moves to allow.
A copper nickel form
[INAUDIBLE] solid solutions.
So what kind of
moves would you do
to equilibrate the system if
you had to set this up yourself?
So again, essentially you
would seed the system, probably
with some concentration
of copper and nickel
except that there's
a lot more atoms.
So how would you do a
Monte Carlo on this?
Remember that you're going
to have an embedded atom
Hamiltonian
essentially, so it's one
that you can fairly
rapidly evaluate.
So in the end, it's a very
simple energy function.
It's a bunch of
pairwise sums and then
you just stick the result in
a function and you're done.
It's not like quantum mechanics.
You have, essentially, a
Hamiltonian you can abuse,
so it's important to realize.
So how would you do
Monte Carlo on this?
This is the one thing--
Monte Carlo is about
choosing your perturbations,
the rest is automatic
after that essentially.
It's just doing
it a lot of times.
So how would you
equilibrate the system?
It's too early in the morning,
you're all still equilibrated.
So first of all, you need
to segregate some species
to the surface assuming
there will be segregation.
So how do you do that?
Again, you could
do diffusive hops.
Diffusive like hops, so do
canonical like interchanges.
You could interchange
them nearby
or you could interchange
them far away.
I got to stick to
my colors here.
So you could interchange
positions of copper and nickel,
but again, the slightly
faster way to do it
is to do it grand canonically,
to define actually
a Hamiltonian that's the energy
minus mu copper, n copper
minus from mu nickel, n nickel.
OK?
And since you're actually
going to be interchanging
the identity of atoms,
n copper and n nickel
are not independent variables.
You keep total number
of atoms constant.
So you can actually write this
as E minus mu copper minus mu
nickle times n copper,
since any change of a nickel
is compensated by
a change of copper.
So we have essentially only one
controlling chemical potential,
which is the difference of
the two species chemical
potentials.
OK.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: If a [INAUDIBLE]
in a specific ratio, nickel
or copper, [INAUDIBLE] very
long to find the correct value
of [INAUDIBLE]?
GERBRAND CEDER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Yes, so you're controlling the
external chemical potential,
so you don't control
the composition.
True.
What people sometimes
do is that--
what's of interest to you is the
bulk chemical potential, that's
the source for the surface.
You first do bulk
simulations and then
you roughly know what
chemical potential corresponds
to what compositions, because
it's actually a little tricky.
While energetically often,
the center of the system
does not influence
the surface much
so you think you
have convergence.
You still deplete
it as a reservoir
as you segregate one
species to the surface,
so that's sometimes
why you actually
need more bulk in the system.
But yes, what you say is true.
If you're only interested
in one composition
it can be better to
stick there with that.
OK.
But let's say you do
these exchange moves.
Do you do it on a lattice?
Do you do it in sort
of a continuous space?
I mean, how would you do it?
This is an FCC solid.
This is an FCC solid solution.
So you could if you want to do
it on a lattice, but would you?
So you know what I
mean with a lattice?
You have pre-defined positions
where the atoms can sit.
Somebody has to be
able to say something.
I'm just going to stand here.
And it's not good because
you're being taped for OCW,
so they're going
to think these MIT
students have nothing to say.
Somebody in Western
Africa sees this
they're going to go
like, why did they
let these people in at MIT?
So what else would you add?
First of all, if you do
it on a fixed lattice,
think of what you end up
with thermodynamically?
What have you sampled?
If you're on a fixed
lattice, you've
sampled the configurational
entropy, essentially
the possible distributions
of copper and nickel
on these fixed lattice sites.
But if one atom is
bigger than the other,
for example, then they don't
sit on a fixed lattice,
then atoms will relax away
from lattice positions.
You will also not sample
vibrational excitation
because you never go away
from your lattice position.
So you could add
small displacements
to the perturbations.
So remember, you
do the sort of big
into the chemical interchange
as you interchange copper
to nickel, but then
to that you could add
small displacements of the atoms
so you not sample deviations
from their
equilibrium positions.
And if you're done
them, then you'll
have both configurational
and vibrational entropy.
So remember that by the
possible perturbations
you pick for your system,
you are essentially defining
the phase space you sample.
So you're defining this phase
space you integrate over
and that's essentially telling
you what forms of entropy
you allow in your system.
Because, you know, what forms
of entropy is the same as what
forms of disorder or excitations
I allow in your system.
OK?
So the cool thing
about it is that you
can look at the effects of both,
and I'll show that in a bit.
You could actually
say, first I'm
going to do it on
a rigid lattice
and I'll see the
result, and then
I'll also include displacement
away from the rigid lattice
and you can look
at the difference,
and that's essentially
telling you
what the effect of
vibrational excitations
are on your thermodynamics.
OK, so here's the result.
You know this was 1985?
You'd be amazed how
easy this is to do now
if you wanted to do
something like this yourself.
With a Hamiltonian-like embedded
atom it really goes very fast
and you could equilibrate
systems like this in no time.
But here's the
result. So this is
a function of the bulk
concentration of copper.
This is the amount of
copper in the first
and second and third layer.
So the green curve
is the first layer.
So clearly, copper segregates
to the surface in this material.
So as you can see, even
for 20% copper in the bulk
you have an almost perfect
copper layer on the surface.
I think this was
actually a 111 surface.
Copper in the second layer,
interestingly, is depleted.
So it's actually below the
average bulk concentration.
And then copper
in the third layer
essentially starts tracking
the bulk concentration.
So why do you think the
copper in the second layer
is depleted?
Because first of all, why
does copper go to the surface?
It has a lower surface energy,
so this is not rocket science.
Most of the time the thing
with the lower surface energy
goes to the surface.
OK?
But why is depleted
in the second layer?
Because I sort of
think, well, this
is the lower surface energy.
Even in the second layer
it's not perfectly bonded,
so maybe it still wants to
enhance its concentration there
but actually depletes it.
This is not atypical, it's very
common surface concentration.
It's actually because copper
and nickel in this system
have an ordering interaction.
So it's the fact that the first
layer is almost pure copper,
but the second layer,
for chemical reasons,
really wants to be nickel.
OK?
And this is a pure
surface effect.
Copper and nickel in
the bulk are actually
at low temperature
phase separating,
but in the surface
because of strain effects
they form an
ordering interaction.
And so the second layer
wants to be nickel
because the first layer
is so much copper.
And so you often see this
in compound forming systems
that you have
damped oscillations
in the concentration
away from the surface.
OK.
So I want to show you one
example of something that
gets much more
complicated, and you'll
see how you start running into
problems with Monte Carlo.
So I've shown you a little
bit how you would detect phase
transitions in Monte Carlo.
You'd look at things
like the heat capacity
especially, particularly
powerful for detecting
second order transitions.
For first order transitions,
you look at discontinuities
in things like
the energy, things
like the relation between mu
and see chemical potential
and concentration, and
you'll pick that up.
The problem you'll face is
often that Monte Carlo systems,
just like real systems, often
face significant hysteresis.
So here's an example from
quite a few years ago
of a fairly complicated
lattice model Hamiltonian.
This, again, was
on an FCC lattice.
This is the palladium
vanadium system, OK?
Phase diagram.
This is palladium on this
side, this side is vanadium,
and this is a lattice model
with a bunch of interactions
in the Hamiltonian.
A nearest neighbor pair,
second neighbor pair,
third neighbor pair, and so on.
Four body interactions, four
body here, three body here.
It's a fairly
complicated Hamiltonian
that tends to give you
a lot of local minima
and how would you get
this phase diagram?
Well, what would you do?
Again, to equilibrate faster you
wouldn't keep the concentration
fixed, you would scan
the chemical potential
and evolve in concentration
from one end to the other.
OK?
Let me actually do
that on the next slide.
So you have some
chemical potential
that gives you the difference
in palladium and vanadium
amounts or the concentration.
OK.
And so you would
plot something like--
so you would have a
driving chemical potential
and you would plot
the average spin,
we'd say is a
concentration of vanadium.
And let's say you scan
at this temperature,
so what would you see?
If you start here, you would
go through a solid solution
regime.
So you would see your
concentration go up when
you hit the two phase region.
OK?
The chemical potential
is constant there,
so that means at that
chemical potential you
have a discontinuity
in the concentration,
so this would go straight up.
Then you would go in
a single phase region.
OK?
So in a single phase region,
the chemical potential
changes rapidly
with concentration.
So there, you actually
tend to be kind of flat.
It's not quite
flat, but it tends
to just be sloped a lot less.
Then you would, again, go
in to a two phase region.
So you would,
again, form a step.
You would go into
a single phase.
So we basically see
this kind of behavior,
and where you have
these discontinuities
in concentration, you would
know that there's a first order
transition.
You could also plot the
energy, and the energy
is discontinuous as well.
The internal energy system is
discontinuous at a first order
transition.
You don't necessarily see
things in the heat capacity.
Now what happens in reality?
If you think about it,
if you come from this end
so you have a
solid solution, you
go through two phase
region, and you
have to form this
compound, which
is called nickel [INAUDIBLE].
So often in Monte Carlo,
just like in a real system,
you have nucleation problems.
If you have to form a phase
or an arrangement that's
extremely different from the
host from which it forms,
it will often just not
nucleate, and well, what happens
is that you will overshoot.
So you will actually push the
disordered phase way too far
out of equilibrium and
then at some point,
you will be so far
out of equilibrium
that you literally shoot
into the ordered phase.
And then what happens
when you come back?
You have hysteresis
the other way.
So you'll overshoot the order
phase sometimes and disorder,
although disordering is
a little easier to do.
So just like in real systems at
strong first order conditions
you'll see a lot of hysteresis,
and it's often very hard
to get rid of.
I think some of you may
have noticed that if you
did the molecular dynamics lab.
Seeing first order transitions
in a molecular dynamics lab,
you also are often
plagued with hysteresis.
I mean, if you study
melting, for example,
it's very asymmetrical
hysteresis.
If you heat up a solid,
it's pretty easy to melt it.
If you cool down a liquid,
it's about impossible
to nucleate the solid
unless you force it.
So there you have enormous
amounts of hysteresis.
So the point of this is that
to study strong first order
transitions,
sometimes the best way
to find their transition
temperatures or concentrations
is not by direct simulation.
Essentially, what
you need to do is go
through a thermodynamic route.
Try to extract free energies
and find where they cross,
because first order
transitions are defined
by where free energies of
the two phases intersect,
and that's by far the most
accurate way of detecting
phase transitions.
There's a real problem
here is that, how
do you get free energy?
The fundamental difference
between free energy and energy
is that energy is
an average quantity
and free energy is not.
See, energy is the
average of something
that is defined in the
microscopic states.
For every microscopic
state I go through,
I can define an energy, and
then the internal energy,
the thermodynamic
energy of the system
is just the average
of that quantity.
For free energy or entropy--
which are essentially the same
because if I know the entropy,
I know the free energy--
it is not the average of
a quantity that's defined
in the microscopic state.
You know?
If you put the atoms
in a fixed position
somewhere with some velocity,
that's a microscopic state.
You cannot define
the entropy of that.
The entropy is a property
of the ensemble as a whole,
not of a given
macroscopic state.
So entropy and free energy
cannot be obtained as averages.
They're actually integrals.
You can see that the entropy
is a sum over all phase
space of this quantity,
P log P. You can write
the free energy same way as an
integrated quantity over all
of phase space of this quantity.
If you rewrite it, you
sort of see it better.
You are averaging something.
If you look at this, you
are averaging something
because you have a
probability here,
but what's the quantity
you're averaging?
It's essentially the
free energy itself.
So it's a quantity that's
flat in phase space.
OK?
So that makes it extremely
difficult to sample.
Actually this is not a
mathematical problem,
this is a physical problem.
It's just the same as
what happens in nature.
You can measure energy,
you can measure volume,
you cannot measure free energy.
There are no free energy
meters because it's
an extensive quantity
that that is determined
by the whole ensemble.
You only really get free
energies ever indirectly.
You can get free
energy difference,
but you get free energy
by integrating lower order
quantities.
OK, so you can write
it as an average
but it's a little misleading.
You can actually write it as
the average of this thing here.
If you can calculate
the exponential
of beta the Hamiltonian and
average that over phase space--
and notice I didn't
make an error there.
I did not drop a minus sign.
It's the exponential
of the positive beta
times the Hamiltonian.
If you can average
that quantity,
you can show that you can
actually have the free energy.
And the proof is
given here, it's
sort of an almost trivial proof.
But you see that's
kind of problematic.
The Hamiltonian is an
extensive quantity,
so it scales with the
size of the system.
So you're taking the exponential
of something that's extensive,
so that gets very big.
So first of all, you can only
do this for finite systems
and for systems that are
really, really small.
Because otherwise,
essentially, that quantity,
the exponential of beta the
Hamiltonian, the difference
between two states
becomes excessively large
as your system size gets
bigger because that quantity
in the exponential is extensive.
OK?
You see, if I'm calculating the
Hamiltonian difference, say,
between two phases, the
Hamiltonian value goes in there
as the extensive quantity.
It's not the normalized one.
It's not the one, say, per unit
cell or something like that.
So that energy
difference is infinite
in the extensive limit, OK?
So even if two phases only are
one joule a part per molecule,
per mol set, one joule per mol.
In the extensive limit, they're
still an infinite energy apart.
OK?
So you can't practically
actually sample that, so
how do people get free energies?
Well, there are
hundreds of papers
on free energy
integration and the reason
that there's
hundreds of papers is
that it's such a difficult thing
and everybody claims to have
the magic potion to do it.
The first thing to realize
is that you almost never need
free energy, you always
need free energy differences
between two things, and
that's a powerful statement
because that's a lot
easier to do as you'll see.
The second thing is
that you probably
shouldn't believe half of
what you read in papers.
I used to track that
field and everybody said,
oh, I have a great method
to get free energies out
of a single simulation, because
that's sort of the problem.
You'll see in a second that
the way we get free energy
is that we have
to do Monte Carlo
at a lot of different points
to get the free energy at one
point.
There's tons of papers
that write that you
can do it with one simulation.
Well, either implicitly
they do a lot of simulations
within that one and
just call it one,
or you can do it
in limited cases
if you know a lot about the
form of your phase space.
So if you have extremely
simple Hamiltonians--
if I give you a nearest neighbor
Ising model, the magnetic model
which is the nearest
neighbor interaction,
essentially the
amount of excitations
out of the low energy
states there is very finite.
Like I said, you could
flip one isolate, spin,
you get a times j.
So you could almost
numerically start writing out
what the free energy becomes.
So in very simple models, if
you know the form of the phase
space, you can actually get
towards free energy models.
In general, it's pretty
much an unsolved problem.
And the way we
practically get it
is with three types of methods.
One is free energy integration,
and I put lambda integration
under there.
I'll show in a
second what it is.
And the second one is
overlapping distribution
methods, which is slightly
less important, especially
for solids.
So it's really only 2 previous
others, which I used to cover
and I don't even do anymore now.
OK.
Let me first show you
overlapping distribution
methods, which I'm less familiar
with because I never use it,
but the idea of it
is quite simple.
So if you want to know the free
energy difference between two
states, remember that
the free energy is KT
log the partition function q.
So the delta, the
difference is the log
of the ratio of the
partition function, OK?
You are with us?
So you can write
out what that is.
The partition
function is the sum
over all the states
of the exponential
of minus beta the Hamiltonian.
If I multiply this
by 1-- and I'm
going to multiply
this by 1, then I'm
going to write 1 as the
exponential of beta H1.
Sorry.
Got to be consistent here.
H1 nu times exponential
minus beta H1.
OK, so that's one.
So then I can collect the
terms here, and what I get
is that I get I still
sum over all the states.
I get the exponential,
the Hamiltonian difference
to n1 weighted by
the probability
of this state in the
ensemble of Hamiltonian one.
This is essentially
the probability
of that state is the
exponential minus beta H
over the partition function
taken with Hamiltonian 1.
So what have I written here?
The exponential of the
probability of that state
weighted in Hamiltonian
1 of this quantity.
So essentially,
what I'm averaging
is the exponential of minus
beta the Hamiltonian difference
between state two and
one, but I average it
in the ensemble of one and
that gives me the free energy
difference.
The reason that's called
overlapping distribution
methods is that--
let me show you
that in a second--
you're trying to say
something about state two,
but you're sampling in
the ensemble of one.
So the only way this
is ever going to work
is if one and 2 are not too far
apart so that the states that
are relevant for two are also
sampled to some extent when
you're in one, and that's
why it's called overlapping
distribution method.
So if I sample in
one, essentially
let's look at the energy.
I sample energy states around
the average with some spread,
spread could be
the heat capacity.
If I'm in two I
do the same thing
around the average
energy of two.
And essentially
what I'm doing is
I'm integrating things
for ensemble two
just by the way I walk
through ensemble one.
And so it's a relatively
elegant way of doing it,
and the key aspect is that the
states in the two ensembles
are the same.
The ensembles are the same,
so the accessible states
are the same, it's just that
you weigh them differently.
So this is almost just like
non-Boltzmann sampling.
I Boltzmann sample
for ensemble one,
but you could say I
non-Boltzmann sample
for ensemble two and I correct
the probability and this is
how I get the free energy.
So you can already see when
this is not going to work.
This is not going to work when
your states are too far apart.
OK.
By far the most
used method to get
free energy is sort of a
trivial one in some sense,
it's free energy integration.
But it's the one
that always works
if you put enough
time in it and it
starts from this
kind of trivial idea
that the difference
in a quantity
is the integral of the
differential, which this is why
you come to MIT to learn this.
So if I can actually
sample this,
I may be able to
get at the quantity
simply by integrating that.
And why is that important?
Because if A is a free
energy or an entropy,
the derivatives of free
energies and entropies
are things that can be
sampled because they
tend to be either
averages or fluctuations.
For example, for
the entropy, you
wanted the entropy
difference between two states
so you integrate the
derivative of the entropy.
Well, the derivative
of the entropy
is the heat capacity
and the heat capacity
you can get from Monte Carlo.
The heat capacity is essentially
the fluctuation of the energy.
So if you want to know the
entropy at a given temperature,
you start from some
reference temperature
where you know the entropy or
you just fix it to some value
if you want to reference
everything to the same thing
and you integrate
the heat capacity.
What do you take as
reference states?
Well, again, you could just
integrate between two states
and get the entropy difference.
Often you start from 0.
If you start from 0
temperature in models
with discrete degrees of
freedoms like the Ising
model, the spin model, the
entropy is 0 at 0 Kelvin
so that's an easy
integration state.
In some cases, you can also
find the entropy at infinity
because in infinity, your
phase space is random,
the probability
distribution is flat,
and so sometimes you can get
analytically the entropy there.
So these are all proper
reference states.
So here's an example.
This is, again, our very simple
2D square magnetic Ising model.
You would essentially
integrate C over T,
so you'd essentially integrate
under this curve from 0 up.
The way you practically
do it is that you
wouldn't start from 0,
because the reason is you're
integrating.
So you're integrating C
over T and that integral,
in reality of course,
converges as T goes to 0.
But numerically, it will
never in your simulation
because T goes to 0
and you force T to 0
in your simulation.
That's a well defined
number, but the heat capacity
will not go to 0 just
because of numerical noise.
In reality, it
should be really 0,
but what will actually
happen is that because
of some minor noise
and fluctuations,
we will get non-zero
heat capacity.
So you divide by a number
that gets exceedingly small
as you go to 0, and so
you're integral will blow up
numerically.
So what you typically do is
you look at your heat capacity
and say, well, below 0.5
or 0.75 I essentially
have no heat capacity.
That means all the
way from 0 to there
I have essentially no
entropy, and you just
start integrating
from 0.5 or 0.75.
If you want to be
more accurate, there
are ways of analytically
writing the heat capacity from 0
to low temperature by
things like low temperature
expansions.
Essentially from
here to about here,
all that would ever happen
is single spin flips.
So you'd have this
ferromagnet sitting there,
once in a while one spin would
go, [FAST-SOUNDING WHISTLE]..
So they're single
excitation so you
can write out what the partition
function pretty much looks
like.
It's the groundstate energy plus
just the first excited states.
So you can write
out analytically
what the entropy
is up to that point
and then integrate from there.
Practically you can integrate a
whole bunch of other variables.
The one that if you
integrate from infinity
that's very practical is to use
the Gibbs-Helmholtz relation.
Gibbs-Helmholtz
relation essentially
tells you that
the average energy
is the derivative of
the free energy over T
with respect to 1 over T. This
is actually a generic relation.
If you think here the
average of any Hamiltonian
is actually the derivative of
its corresponding free energy
over T with respect to 1 over T.
OK.
So if you do this in
a canonical system,
then you're Hamiltonian's
like the energy
minus mu times
some concentration.
So then that's the average
quantity you would get here.
Why is this useful?
Because essentially now you're
integrating in 1 over T,
so in beta, and that
quantity is 0 when
you're at infinite temperature.
So beta is 0 and
T equals infinity.
So now this is an easy way
to integrate from infinity.
Why do you want
integrate from infinity?
Like I said before, sometimes
that infinite temperature,
you know the free
energy analytically,
because everything is totally
random and so something that's
a useful integration state.
Another one that's
quite practical
is simply integrating
in composition,
and that's why I sort of
shown this on this phase
because it shows the three
major ways of integration.
If you come from
low temperature,
you integrate the heat capacity.
If you come from
high temperature,
you use the
Gibbs-Helmholtz relation
to integrate the average
Hamiltonian, so the energy
most cases.
If you come from the sides, you
integrate in composition space.
So you integrate
essentially sigma d mu,
and the reason is
that the composition--
let me write in regular
thermodynamic variables--
is essentially derivative
of free energy with respect
to the chemical potential.
So when you integrate that--
I've written composition here
as the average spin in a spin
model, so you integrate Cd
mu, and that gives you dF
and so that's essentially
what this here is.
Why can you integrate
from the sides?
Well, if you have pure 1--
so you call this A or
B. If you have pure A,
you know the free
energy in many cases
because if you have a model with
only configuration entropy when
you have pure A, you
have no configuration
entropy so the free energy
there is just the energy.
OK?
So in some sense, if you
think of this phase diagram
as this line going to
infinity, you essentially
know the thermodynamic
properties at all four edges
and then you can integrate.
This is by far the most accurate
way of determining first order
transitions, by far.
The reason is that
you can get the answer
as accurately as you want it.
So you have to integrate
now along a path, that's
the painful thing.
So if I like the
free energy here,
I don't have to
just simulate here,
I have to simulate pretty
much all the way up from here.
So rather than simulating
at one set of conditions,
I got to simulate
along a whole path.
But the nice thing is that--
so where does your
error come from?
It comes from things
you all control.
You know, how long I've
sampled at each state
to get the quantity I'm
integrating, like heat capacity
or energies.
You can control that.
If you want it better,
you sample longer.
How many steps I take
along the integration path,
so now you're numerically
integrating along a part.
If I want that more
accurate, I take more steps.
So while it looks difficult,
you have all the properties
under control.
So that's the nice
thing, that you
know how to make it better
if you don't like the answer.
The only thing to
keep in mind when
you free energy integration,
that you have to iterate
through equilibrium states.
These thermodynamic
relations do not
hold when you're away
from equilibrium states.
So if you integrate
through transitions,
then you want to be absolutely
sure that that transition is
occurring in equilibrium,
and that's often the problem,
and that's why we combine
all these schemes.
Like if I want to get,
say, this phase boundary,
I would probably integrate
one phase up from here to here
and then I would integrate
either the solid solution
from the side or from
infinity to that point.
OK?
So I would never try to get the
solid solution by integrating
from the ordered phase
through the transition
into the solid solution
because I get way
too much error from
non-equilibrium phenomena
at the transition.
OK.
Then we come to the last form of
free energy integration, which
is a form of
thermodynamic integration
that has a bit of a science
fiction component to it.
Come on.
OK.
Anyway, I think I've
said all these things.
What the advantages
and disadvantages are,
thermodynamic integration.
You can actually do something
a little more fancy or esoteric
in thermodynamic
integration, which
tends to go by the name
of lambda integration.
What I showed you before was you
were integrating with respect
to derivatives of
physical parameters,
like temperature
or concentration
or 1 over temperature.
You can actually
integrate with respect
to nonphysical parameters.
For example, I may want
to get the free energy
difference between
systems that have
two different Hamiltonians.
What would that mean?
Maybe I want to know
how to free energy
change if I turn on a certain
interaction in the Hamiltonian.
Like maybe I want to know, I
turn on Coulombic interactions
and I want to know, how
does this really affect
the free energy of my system?
Maybe I want to add a particle.
You could think of actually
changing the temperature
as a way of changing
your Hamiltonian,
because the thing you
put in the exponential
is beta times Hamiltonian, so
it's really kind of one unit.
It's when you
change that product
that you're changing something
to the probability density.
I'll show you some cool
examples of this in a second,
but let me show
you how it works.
So now you're going to integrate
along a path of lambda that
essentially describes how
you go from Hamiltonian 1
to Hamiltonian 2.
And Hamiltonian 2 could be
totally different physics,
it could be different
chemistry, whatever.
So I'm going to
write the Hamiltonian
as a linear combination of the
Hamiltonians of 1 and 2, OK?
So now you see, as
lambda goes from 0 to 1,
if I'm 0 I have
Hamiltonian 1, if I'm
one I have Hamiltonian 2.
OK?
So the integral
0 to 1 for lambda
defines the past one
which I integrate.
So what I want to
know is essentially
the free energy between
lambda is 1 and 0--
but I'll get the free
energy along the whole path,
as you'll see in a second.
You can see how
you can get that.
If you look at the derivative
of the free energy with respect
to lambda, well, the
free energy is the log
of the partition function.
So if I take the
derivative of that,
you can sort of
do the math here.
If I take a derivative
of these exponentials
I get the exponential
back, so that's
going to give me a
partition function.
Because remember, if I
take derivative of the log
I get 1 over this thing.
So you know, I get log z.
When you take the derivative of
that, I'm going to get 1 over z
and then times d, z,
d, whatever I'm taking
the derivative of with respect.
So that gives me that
partition function here.
And then I take the derivative
of what's inside the log
and that gives me this.
And essentially what
shows up is the derivative
of the Hamiltonian
with respect to lambda,
and this is actually classic.
This always happens.
If you take any derivative
of the partition function,
you essentially always end
up with a weighted derivative
of the Hamiltonian.
And so what you see is
this is the probability,
this exponential weighted
by q is the probability.
So essentially what this
free energy derivative is,
it's the average of the
derivative of the Hamiltonian
with respect to lambda.
OK?
This is actually quite generic
in statistical mechanics.
So the quantity that you need
to integrate is this derivative.
Now if we've linearized
our Hamiltonian,
that derivative is just
Hamiltonian difference.
OK?
But this is actually
more generically true.
But if you linearize
it, all you need to do
is average the
Hamiltonian difference.
So I'm going to show
you an example which
I got out of this paper,
which is hidden here by--
kind of move this thing.
There we go.
And this was a study
where they wanted
to look at the effects
of a water dipole
on the free energy of water.
And so the reason you have a
dipole in water is, of course,
you have H2O--
how does this work again?
So the hydrogens are
slightly positively charged
and so this is then minus
2 times that quantity.
And so because of that, you of
course, have a dipole which--
does a dipole point from
positive to negative
or, yeah, from negative
to positive dipoles?
Well, whatever.
We'll define it this way.
So you have a dipole moment
and in a simple simulation,
you can essentially
just represent the water
by its dipole, nothing else.
No atoms, no molecules.
So you want to look at
the dipole interactions
between water.
Now if you want to look at
how does the free energies
change with the strength of
that dipole, for example,
you could write dipolar strength
in terms of some parameter
lambda, and that's
what I've done here.
So the positive and the
negative charge in the dipole
depend on the parameter
lambda, and so essentially
what I'm going to do is
look at the free energy
as a function of lambda.
And let me show
you how it works.
The green line here, there's a
few too many lines on this plot
unfortunately.
This is the exact result--
and actually, this
was well parameterized
because at 0 and 1 you
should get the same answer
because when lambda is 1, the
dipole is the same as at 0,
it's just inverted the
plus n minus charge.
OK?
So the purple line is what they
got with lambda integrations
paper, so it does pretty well.
I mean it's this
line here, sorry.
But what you see is there's
of course a bit of error.
This point should be the
same as that point, OK?
And so you clearly see that
they accumulated some error
along the integration path.
And if you're really
hard core computational
and you think this is
fun, this is one way
you can check your integration
errors is essentially
do a circular integration
in your phase space.
So not only go from Hamil
state 1 to 2, but come back
and you essentially
have some idea
of the error you've accumulated
along the integration path.
This one, the next one
I like as an example.
This is starting to get
very close to alchemy.
You know, in the old days people
tried to turn lead into gold.
This is getting pretty close.
You can look at
three energy changes
literally by changing chemistry.
I know nothing about
organic chemistry,
but I think that ring
there is called the phenyl
and so you can put different
groups on the phenyl
and if you put chlorine
on it, it's chlorophenyl.
If you pull a methyl
group on its methylphenyl,
and if you put a cyan
group it's cyanophenyl.
So there's clearly some
logic in chemical names.
But for example, you
could write a Hamiltonian
that slowly changes one of
these species into another one.
And what does that
mean, slowly change?
That means that you
mix the interaction.
Let's say you did
this with potential,
you would essentially write
a potential from that group.
Potential that comes from this
group here that you attach
has a weighted average of--
let's say we go from,
like we did here,
methylphenyl to chlorophenyl.
So you would weigh the potential
with the parameter lambda
and integrate in
that space and you'd
get the free energy
difference between these two
groups attached.
OK.
So here's my take
on Monte Carlo.
What I really like about it,
it's conceptually simple.
Of all the simulation
methods, it's
probably the one that has
the least amount of frills.
It tends to be very
easy to implement.
And maybe the most
important thing,
it's as accurate
as your Hamiltonian
can be so you can push
the sampling as far as you
want it to be.
So the sampling part can be done
as accurately as you have time
for, essentially.
Time and money for.
Which is not always
true about models.
If I set up a potential
model, I can't necessarily
improve that infinitely
better to model
the energetics of my system.
But at least with Monte
Carlo, the sampling part, so
the finite temperature part can
be done with as little error
as you'd like it to be.
I think there's
sort of two or three
major disadvantages is that
it's not a dynamical method,
so it doesn't give you
any kinetic information
like molecular dynamics does.
Sometimes that's an
advantage because it
means you don't need
a kinetic mechanism
to study how the system goes
through it's phase space.
But the second one is the
major hit most of the time.
It's an extremely
wasteful method
in terms of energy evaluations.
You do a lot of kind of
random excursions in phase
space and every time you
need to get the energy,
and so that's why it's
really great to implement it
with fast energy methods.
You know, [INAUDIBLE] small
Hamiltonian G. That's just
adding a few numbers and
multiplying a few numbers
and you got the energy, bam!
Or something like
potential models
if you do it in a continuous
space or embedded atom
works great with those methods.
It's essentially impossible
to implement it with quantum
mechanics directly, you know?
I mean, that embedded.
The method, the
copper nickel one
I showed you did millions
of energy evaluations
to equilibrate the system.
So can you imagine you're
going to millions of direct DFT
calculations?
No.
So that the fact that
you need typically
a fast energy method is
sort of a limitation.
The stochastic nature of
it can be a limitation.
It's less and less so, but
when you run two Monte Carlo
simulations you don't
get the same answer,
so because of that,
there is noise in data.
It's a lot harder to write
methods on top of it,
in some sense, drivers for it.
If you do DFT, if
you converge, you
get the same answer every time.
So it's not stochastic.
So you can now develop
algorithms that use that input
and do stuff with it.
It's a lot harder to work
with stochastic input,
let me tell you, because you
kind of have to average noise
away.
And I think the fourth one--
you know, I should update.
This is becoming less
and less an issue.
It used to be, but as computers
get faster it's really,
I would say we can
get free energy when
we want it, especially on
models with discrete degrees
of freedom.
Models with continuous degree
of freedom you can do it.
There's still more work, but
it's not much of a disadvantage
anymore.
OK, I've gone through
the references Before.
OK.
So what I want to
start maybe now--
and I'm probably
not going to get
this finished-- is start to talk
about coarse-graining methods.
And why do you need
coarse-graining methods?
it's essentially a nice follow
up on what we just discussed.
Monte Carlo allows you to get
full phase space sampling,
but you cannot do it on an
accurate Hamiltonian like
density functional theory.
So what if you actually need
highly accurate energetics
and you need to sample
phase space well?
Then you're in trouble
because the two
are very hard to combine.
Sampling phase
space, well, means
a lot of energy evaluations
and a lot of energy evaluations
precludes using a very
highly accurate Hamiltonian,
but there are problems for
which you need both anyway.
And then you sort of need to
go to coarse-graining methods.
And the idea in
coarse-graining methods
is that you try to either remove
spatial degrees of freedom
or temporal degrees of
freedom or your system
very systematically so
that your model becomes
simpler and simpler, giving up
as little accuracy as possible.
OK?
So accumulating as little
error on the way as possible.
I'll talk first about
temporal coarse-graining
since it's easier, but if
we have time in the end
I may say a little about spatial
coarse-graining, which is
a much more difficult problem.
OK, let me skip this.
OK.
Well, actually let
me show it to you.
Something wrong
with the color here.
Here's an example of why
you need coarse-graining.
This is the copper,
aluminum phase diagram.
All the stable
phases in here are
in many cases within something
like 5 to 10 milli electron
volt of several other phases.
So that means that
to actually know
that these are the stables
facing that system,
you need highly
accurate energetics.
You can't afford more than a
few million electoral votes
to an error.
That's a very small error.
So an election volt is
about 100 kilojoules,
so a million electron
volt is about 100 joules.
All right.
Yeah.
So I don't know what
that in calories is,
but anyway, so highly
accurate energetics
and then to get the
temperature behavior
you need to sample
phase space because you
need to get the entropy
and the excitations.
For some problems like
these, essentially we
figured out how to do this.
It's still hard work, but
essentially the road map
is laid out.
The idea is that you
successively integrate over
slower and slower timescales.
So you look at what
excursions, what excitations
occur in the system, first at
the really fast time scales
and then you try to either
variationally remove them
or you try to
integrate over them,
and those two are
different things.
If you variationally
remove a degree of freedom,
then you're really
finding, essentially,
what gives you the lowest energy
for that degree of freedom.
If you integrate
over the excursions
of that degree of freedom,
then essentially you
capture its full
entropic component,
and I'll come back to the
distinction between the two.
But let's take, for
example, a simple binary
solid, like that aluminum
copper I showed you.
What are the excitations
in that system?
Well, it's a metal so at the
highest level there's probably
electronic excitations.
If the Fermi level of the
system cuts through a band
so you have density of
states at the Fermi level,
then electrons can get excited
across the Fermi level.
OK?
So that's a form of entropy
right there already.
Most of the time we
don't worry about it.
That's one that we
variationally remove.
You do the FT and you find
the lowest energy state.
You don't say, I'm
going to integrate
over all the accessible
electronic states.
You find the lowest one.
Then you have
vibrational excitations.
These are ones you
can get around.
They're essentially present in
every material by definition.
These live on timescale
10 to the minus 11,
10 to the minus 12, 10
to the minus 13 seconds.
And then typically the slower
one is configurational ones.
If you have just A and B that
they interchange positions,
they start giving you disorder.
Again, the reason you can
sort of do this problem easily
is that this would be
the perfect Monte Carlo
problem, just like in
that copper nickel example
segregation.
If you could do fast
energy evaluations,
you would just do
small displacements
to capture the
vibrations and then
you would do big
exchanges to capture
the configurational excitations.
But because you
need the accuracy,
you'd almost need to do
it on a DFT Hamiltonian.
You could say the
vibrational ones
you could capture very well
with molecular dynamics.
You just track the
displacements of the atoms.
Think about it, the
sort of slower phonons
go on a timescale of
maybe 10 to the minus 11.
So what is that?
That's 10 picoseconds.
So if you simulate 100
picoseconds in nanoseconds,
you're going to start
fairly allegorically
sampling the vibration.
So you'd have a
pretty good result
for vibrational free
energy, but you'd never
get down to the
configurational timescale.
So how do you
solve that problem?
Again, the idea is
that we integrate over
the fast degrees
of freedom and try
to define a
Hamiltonian that's only
defined in the phase space of
the slow degrees of freedom.
OK?
And the question is how
accurate can we do this?
So I'm going to focus
on this alloy problem
just so that we keep our focus.
So what I want to get to is a
Hamiltonian that has integrated
away the electronic excitations,
the vibrational excitations,
and therefore that just
lives in the phase space
of the substitutional
excitations, which
is a much smaller phase space.
OK.
Let me show you the math.
If you think of a
crystal of A and B atoms,
they may live on a
lattice, but of course they
can be displaced
from the lattice
just through static
relaxation but also
through vibrational excursions.
So normally you could
define that system
just by coordinate vectors.
If I have n atoms, I need
n coordinate vectors.
I'm going to change the way
I characterize that system
by first, a lattice index.
So this is a topological index.
This is essentially if I
have a crystalline material,
I could start indexing
the possible sites
in that material.
So I will be the index of
these possible lattice sites
and delta r will be the
displacement from these lattice
sites.
OK?
So do you agree that the
combination of these two
is essentially the same as
having a full coordinate?
OK.
Now the set of indices i I'm
going to represent essentially
by a lattice model.
So the set of indices i is
essentially saying at each
lattice point or around
there-- because the atom
doesn't exactly have to sit
there, but around there--
is it an A or a B there?
So the variables
to describe that
are the same variables as a
spin model or lattice model,
it's a binary problem now.
OK?
So the question is,
at I is it A or B?
But again, I don't need to
specify that the atom exactly
sits at A or B. That I specify
by the displacements, the delta
r's, OK?
So what I've done is
I've separated variables
that give me the configurational
topology from the variables
that gives me the excursions
away from the ideal lattice
site.
And now you see where I'm going.
I'm going to integrate
over the excursions
and then retain
something that only
exists in the space of the
configurational degrees
of freedom.
OK, here we go.
So the partition function
is the sum over all states.
So again, the sum
over all states
you would have normally be
the sum over all vectors.
I'm going to write that as the
sum over configurational states
and then the sum over all
displacement states, which
have called nu.
So nu is the set of delta
ri, and so the energy
depends on both variables.
OK?
Now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to essentially assume
I can do this integration.
We'll talk in a second
about how you can do that.
So I'm only going to do the
sum over the displacement,
but for a given
configurational state.
So what does that
practically mean?
That means that I'm integrating
the phase space of a fixed
topology, but allowing the
atoms to sort of vibrate
around their average positions.
That's essentially
what I'm doing.
So essentially I'm
capturing, in that integral,
the vibrational free
energy component
for a given configuration.
And so I'm going to define.
So this is that integral
we talked about.
So I'm going to give
that a free energy, which
is just the logarithm of that.
And then just if I
substitute that in here,
you see that what I
end up with is this
and this is kind of important.
What do I have?
I have the partition
function of a lattice model.
I have a partition
function that only
sums over different
topologies, it only
configurational states, OK?
So I've reduced the phase space.
I'm not summing over
vibrational states.
Remember, I've integrated them.
But what is the
quantity I'm summing?
This is the important thing.
The quantity I'm summing
is not the energy,
it's the free energy of
the vibrations essentially.
OK?
So as you coarse-grain
in time, your Hamiltonian
at the slower timescale is
essentially the free energy
of the faster timescale.
OK?
Why?
Because you
successively integrate.
So in essence, if I sum
over lattice model stage
and I put A's and B's on
different lattice positions,
what this is telling you
is that the quantity--
that's my Hamiltonian-- is
not the energy of that state.
It's the vibrational free
energy of that state.
So if I take that
as my Hamiltonian
and then I do this
partition function,
I will essentially
have an exact result.
I will have the exact partition
function of the system.
OK?
And that's pretty amazing
because I've really
sort of separated the timescale,
integrate over them separately,
but I get what's
essentially still--
it's an almost exact
result, because let's say
I'm going to do it this way.
So let's say on this
I do Monte Carlo now.
There is a small assumption
that I've made in all of this.
Think of the physical
picture here.
Essentially what I'm
saying is that I got
these A's and B's sitting on--
you can't call them
exactly lattice site,
but they're associated
with a given lattice site.
They may be displaced from it,
and they sort of vibrate around
and I integrate that
those vibrations to get
the vibrational free energy.
And then once in a while
they hop, exchange,
and if I sample that that
gives me the free energy coming
from that slower timescale.
There's one assumption
I've made in all of this.
It's sort of a subtle
one, but I've essentially
assumed that the time
scales are uncoupled,
and here you have to be
careful with what I say.
I say the timescales
are uncoupled.
I don't mean the
energetics is uncoupled.
Obviously the
vibrational free energy
depends on the configuration.
If I arrange the
atoms differently
over the lattice sites, I get
a different vibrational free
energy.
That's not the problem.
I've assumed that you
can define a free energy.
OK?
That this thing exists.
So what does that
physically mean?
What I assume is that for a
given lattice model state,
the system actually
waits long enough
before it goes to the next one.
If it actually only did
one vibration and bam,
it goes to the other one,
then the system is not
ergodic in its vibration.
And what that means
is essentially
it doesn't sample
all its vibrations
before it goes
onto the next one.
So it's the fact that I can
separate the excitation that
really allows me to do this.
Now in most materials, this
is no problem whatsoever.
So vibrations, again, these are
timescale 10 to minus 11, 10
to the minus 13 kind of range.
The exchanges between
atoms on lattices
depends on the
diffusion constant,
but you're going
to be hard pressed
to find any solid where
that happens faster
than of a rate of, say, 10 to
the 4 per second, for example.
10 to the 4, 10 to
the 5 per second.
That's really fast diffusion.
That gives you diffusion
constants of like 10
to the minus 7, 10 to minus
8, which are very high.
Extremely high.
So at room temperature,
for a lot of--
say for metals, this is well
below one hop per second.
Fast conductors you start to
get to a few hops per second
at room temperature.
Then of course,
if you go higher,
temperature goes faster,
but almost always are
these timescales
extremely well separated.
Places where they might not
be like fast proton motion.
They might not be
very well separated
and then this stuff breaks down.
But remember, if they move
that fast, you should just
do molecular dynamics because
then it's within the range.
It's well within the scope
of molecular dynamics,
and that's the perfect
approach at that point.
OK.
OK, let me do one more
thing and then we'll stop.
There's a variety of
approximations you can do.
Remember that your Hamiltonian
in your lattice model
should be the free energy of
the higher order states, which
are essentially the vibrational
and the electronic excitations
that you've removed.
Now in some cases
people say, I don't
want to do all that
work of integrating
over the electronic
states and integrating
over the vibrational states.
I'm going to
variationally remove
them, which means I'm
going to find the lowest
energy electronic states and
the lowest energy displacement
state, delta ri state.
OK?
So I do that
practically while you
take an arrangement
of atoms and you just
relax them both the electronic
states and the positions
to the minimum energy, and
that gives you some E value.
So what it essentially
is is if you
think of the F as the free
energy of an ensemble,
the E you take is the lowest
energy value in that ensemble.
So if you do that and then
you stick that in Monte Carlo,
what do you have?
You have proper
energetics and you only
have configurational
entropy because rather
than integrating all the
vibrations and the electronics
states, you've taken the minimal
state out of that sub-ensemble.
You'll integrate
over-- that means
essentially your system
hasn't sampled excursions
for those variables,
so you don't have
entropy from those variables.
OK?
And then you can do all
kinds of approximation.
You can say, well, I don't
care about the vibrations.
I think that's too much work.
I'm going to just get
the electronic entropy.
And one of the reasons
electronic entropy and metals
is easy, any time you
have delocalized states,
you can write as
a simple integral
over the density of
states, which you often
have [INAUDIBLE] density
functional theory.
So if you say I'm going
to take the minimal energy
and the electronic
entropy, well then
after you've done
your Monte Carlo,
you have configurational
entropy and electronic entropy.
And then if you want
to go all the way,
rather than minimizing the
energy you integrate over
to displacement,
then you're going
to get the vibrational
entropy component as well.
OK.
I'm going to stop here
because the rest is going
to take us a little too long.
And so I'll pick some
of this up again.
It's unfortunately almost
two weeks away from now,
I think, because like I said,
so Tuesday's no lecture.
Thursday-- oh, wait
Thursday's you, no?
Yeah, so actually Thursday's
a lecture by Professor Marzari
and then it's the next Tuesday's
the lab and then Thursday
after that I pick
this up again and then
I think we're in
May or something
and we're almost over.
Anyway, so have a good--
what is this holiday again?
[INAUDIBLE] Day?
No?
OK.
Watch the marathon.